石森主です
私
いまご荘櫂いただきましたように
理論物理学者ですが量子コンピューターの基礎的な研究をしています
量子コンピューターの説明を分かりやすく15分でするというのは
絶対無理ですのでね
今日はすっぱり諦めて
どうして物理の言及からコンピューターそれも量子コンピュータに戦っ
そこまでお話しすることにしてよしコンピュータ自体のお話はまた次の嫌い
ということにし期待したいと思います
多久市
物理の中でも統計力学という運用
統計力学というと時計の力学ですかっ
さっきの
同じ文字に別の言葉が対応する
統計リディアです
何でしょう
ここに水があります
これ液体の水です
この水を
ねしていくと
どんどん上8て言って
100ように達すると沸騰は始まって水蒸気になってなくなってしまいます
液体が気体になります
冷やしていくと
冷たくなって
ロイドで凍って氷になります
なんでこんなことを言うのでしょうか
これ当たり前の現象ですね凍ったり沸騰したりするん
なんでこんな当たり前の事をわざわざ難しく研究して
思われるかもしれませんが
実は
現象の背後には常に深い神事がある
ここにボールがあります
してマジ子ができます
ボールを落とします下に落ちます
当たり前ですん
でもニュートンはこれは当たり前と思わないでー
りんごは
地面に落ちるのを見て
これは
万有引力というのがあって
りんごと地球の間に力が働いて
方が地球に向かって落ち地球はリンゴに向かって惹きつけられ
そういうことを言ったわけです
当たり前のことを難しくいったわけです
そこまでだったらそれだけそれだけなんですが彼はさらに踏み込んでいっ
りんごと地球の間だけではなくて
地球と
太陽の間ん
同じ万有引力を働いている考えて太陽の周りを地球がぐるぐるぐるグルー
回り続けられるのは万有引力のおかげだ
それがないと飛んでいってしまう
あるいは
月が地球の周りをグルグル回り続けられるのも同じ万有引力
こういう世界観が停止した
これは当時の常識からするととんでもない構え方です
しかもあれはそれをこういう言葉でいただけではなくて
微分積分を発明して
力学をつくってしまう現代物理学をつくってしまった
そういうふうに当たり前のことを
ずーっと突き詰めていくのものすごく回心理がある
しかも
ニュートン力学ってのは現在の我々の生地で生活を支えています例えばこの食べ物を
作るようになって
設計は力学を使ってるわけです
new てもいなかった我々の今頃ホラーに住んでいます
もちろん嘘です
それで党経理逆に戻りましょうじゃあなんで
これは
れしていくと水蒸気になりケアしていくと氷になるのか
実はこの水を
細かく見て行くぞ
英智つ大手運針
見えてきます
水素2つと酸素があって分子を使って作ってる h 2を
それがたくさんあるわけです
水も
水蒸気もこうにも
全部同じ h 2 o です小さ詰めていくとミクロな世界
で見ていくと全部同じです
でも
物理学ではこういう日常のスケールのことマクロ汗かいてありますがマクロな世界に
なると水と水蒸気で氷ってのは全然違うわけです
全く同じものがたくさん集まっているだけなのになんでこんな見てマクロに見ると違う
ufc なことですそれは
水の分子が引き合って相互作用と言いますが相互作用しているから
ひき会おうとしているので温度を上げると温度というのはこれが速くなろう
早くおっ
様子なんですが配分動こうとすると権力を引きでバラ針なぜ来たいなぁ
温度を下げると
くっつく力の方が強くなって固まってしまってこれ
要するにたくさんの物が
構成要素基本的な要素がたくさんあってそれらが相互作用している
いうことがこういうマクロな
現象人
ために重要だと思っ
実は右脳の中でも同じことが起きています皆さん一つの思ってますね
脳というのはもちろん成体ですから生きたからですから
細胞でできています神経細胞と言いますニューロ
と言います
ニューロンがただバラバラにあって勝手に何かやってただけでは
何も出来ません
ニューロンが
信号を及ぼし合って影響を及ぼし合って相互作用しあって非常に複雑な
情報処理ができているんですこれもやっぱり脳の中にはニューロンが約
数105あると言われていますが素数や国のニューロンが
たくさんあって相互作用している
そうするとこういう複雑なことができるわけです
考えてみると私がこうやって喋って皆さんがそれを理解しているっていうのは
ものすごく素晴らしいことです
不思議なことです
しゃべることを頭の中で抽象的に見立てて
それを日本語という言語にしその言語に対応する空気
ナビを作るためにしたと口を微妙に動かしています
その能力も一人取り思っているんですこれはもうすごく驚くべきことです
そういう2つのことができるのも
4 s 構成要素であるニューロンがたくさんあってそれらが信号及ぼし合って相互
作用しているぞ
いうことが重要なんですん
実は後で申し上げますよねー
水と
脳ってのはある意味の帽子的に同じなんです
また話は変わります
機械学習
あるいは人工知能という言葉を聞いたことがある人が多いと思います
機械学習あるいは人工知能という分野のある側面では
今申し上げましたような脳がいい
どういうもに相互作用している買う
いうことを
コンピューター上で真似て
コンピュータ以上で仮想的に生成した行
を預かっただけます
コンピュータ上で考え出した基本的な構成要素の間のつながり
相互作用をうまく調整すると外からの信号に対して非常に思うように面白い反応する
ように調整することができるこれもやっぱり構成要素がたくさんあって
それらの相互作用がうまくできてるから
機会があっ
1件知能を持っているように反応できる
でいま申し上げた水が蒸発したり折ったりする現象
脳が僕雑な情報を処理をする
という出来事
あるいは
機会がある
何か外からの刺激に対して治療を持っているように反応する
これは実はなんとなく言葉の上で同じというだけではなくて
数式の上でまったく同じ形で書けるんです
ん
そういうわけで
水の性質を
研究するのに発展してきた
統計力学道
いう分野の
研究が実は
機械学習言われる
維持にあり工学あるいは情報カードの問題に適用できることがわかってきましたん
また話があります量子力学です
量子力学というのは
物理の中でも
難しくて分かりにくい一番わかりにくいということで定評のあると思うんです
でも簡単です
良尻キャプというのは英語で言うとこのため母ミックス
quantum は漁師
力学は目カーン靴
今たむめカーンつっ
量子力学
簡単3感じます簡単に貼れます
簡単な力があっというわけでねー
を添えることはないです
であっ
量子力学入門の入門の入門をやります
私はここに立ってますね
見えますか
あそこに思います見えますか
実は量子力学では私はここにもあそこにも同時に存在するんです
もう少し正確に言うと私がここにいる確率はほとんど100%
あそこにいる確率はほとんど0%です
本当のゼロじゃないんです実は大
宇宙の年齢よりも長く待ってもあそこに見つからないほど確率が小さいです
ん
という意味で実際はいないんですが
量子力学にはここにいる確率とあそこにいる
確率
ここにあそこに同時に存在するという言い方をします
それで私のような
マクロな物体つまり日常生活の物体では100%0%とはっきり分かれますが小さな
世界
原子分子の世界になると実は確率が100%0%からずれています
原氏は真ん中にある大きな
すぐ原子核の周りを原子を回っている
話を聞いたことがあるかと思います
しかしこの
電子っていうのは実はここにもあるし
あっちにもある
同時に存在します
ここにある確率が50%
あそこにある確率が50%
見てみるとある時にはこっちにある
別の時にはこっちにある
見ることに半々の確率であちらこちらに見つかります
こういう意味で
マグロな物体の場合には確率が100と0に分かれていますが
ミクロな物になると
ごぶごぶあるいは64ぐらいになっています
なぜか聞かないでください私知りません
この世界は誰もしれません
ノーベル賞もんだもらった学者でもしれません
銀河系の外にがわかりませんが
この地球の中で誰も知れませんそれが実は自然の一番奥深い
下 b な資材の心理だっ
いうことを認めてそこから出発して議論を組み立てるというのは量子力学です
そんな怪しげだ
出発でぇー
ちゃんとした物理がちゃんとした物理論ができるのかと思われるかもしれませんが
量子力学が
もたらす結果計算の結果ってのはことごとく実験たっていう
100%です
量子力学が間違った結果を出したという例は今まで一つも見つかってないです
節不思議だけどそれは事実です
そこでまた話ががあります
ようやくコンピュータんです
物理量子コンピュータんです
コンピューターの中ではいろんな複雑なことをやってますが結局は
数を計算している数を1と0-1かゼロのビットで表している
1か01ビットと言いますそれが例えば救護並ぶとキュービット
と言います
でこれを
少しずつ計算して
数を変えながら複雑な情報処理をしていうのがコンピュータです
どんな複雑な情報所為でも例えば
スマホでサールとほとんど瞬時に地球の裏側の情報をここに表示されます
それも結局は分解するとこういう
ビッド別といいますが0と1が並んだやつビット列を次々に計算して回転っていう
これだけなんです
ここで覚えていってほしい覚えていて欲しいことがあります
ビット列ビットの並びはゼロかイチがこの例でしたら9個並んだもん
ペンに一つの数しか表せません
量子ビットじゃあこれ量子力学が組み合わせるとどうなるかん
漁師フィギュア付ではこちらにもこちらにも同時に存在できる
5分後の確率
そうすると1か
0ではなくて1とっ
せようっていうのがあっ
できるようになります
量子ビットを持ってくると1問う0が同時に表現できます
そうするとこれを二つ持ってくると1と0が2つあって
合わせて4つの状態が
に量子ビットを使うだけで表現できます
11か1001か
3つ持ってくるとその場合-8
この状態が同時に表現できます
どんどんどんどん倍々ゲームデー
これを10個並べるとさっきの普通のビッドだと
0と1が10個並んだだけで一つ一つのかせたんですが
量子ビットを10個なると1024この状態が同時に表現できます
20量子ビットを持ってくると100万個の数字が同時に表現できます
ものすごく大きな稼が
倍々ゲームで表現できるわけですこれが業種コンピューターがものすごく速い
計算ができる可能性がある理由です
我々の研究室で
1998年に
こういう
基礎的な考え方に基づいて
機械学習の問題のある種の問題を
量子力学を使って量子ビットを使って
処理するとものすごくアヤ役に立つことができるということを提案しました
それは実は
十数年の時を経て
我々が提案した理論の通りん
ものとして製品としてからならベンチャーをつくってそれを15億円という値段で
売り出してそれをアメリカのみんなが知っている
巨大 it 企業はか
ロケットを打ち上げているアメリカの
制度にガンなど
そういう時代になってきました
驚くべきことです
研究というのは思うように段位書かないのは当たり前です
なんかやとこういう方向を目指して一生懸命こう
研究しているんですがこっちから行ってみてもうまくいかないクチかやってみてもは
いかないと
散々試みているうちに実はこっちの方頑張っています
いうことにいつのまにかなってたということがよくあります
とにかく
これに当たると面白くてやめられないです
しかも学問的に面白いだけじゃなくてこういう社会に大きなインパクトを与えるような
結果に結び付いてくると本当に
死にきれないです
あとは150年くらい行きたいな
これからも楽しんでいきたいとおもいます
どうも荒れるます